so now you're going to go ahead and
create the new composite indexes so
first of all open data store dash
indexes auto XML you may find its blank
you may find it's got some content in it
already either way it's fine then run
the query on localhost then go back to
eclipse and check the data store indexes
dash ordered or XML file and you should
find that the new composite index has
been automatically added to it now that
you've updated the index file go ahead
and deploy your app to app spot in the
developers console go ahead and look in
the index viewer is your new composite
index preparing you might find that it's
already ready and that's just fine if it
is when your index is ready run the
query and make sure that it works